hi I'm Steven Davis I'm the head of the
library's digital program here at
Columbia and I have the pleasure of
introducing the next group speakers come
sit down don't have to stand in the
wings we're moving on to now to really
interesting projects having to do with
platform strategies one for scaling up
to bigger and bigger big data and the
other for creating innovative and
effective ways to actually create web
archives while also serving other
purposes the same time so we have first
the work based project and Jimmy Lynn
University of Maryland an associate
professor there with multiple
appointments at least today and uh and I
and Ian Milligan all from the University
of Waterloo is that right yes who a late
arrival and then after that we have
jiwoo sheer and and prashant chandra
sekhar to talk about the uninterruptible
web service project that they've been
working on at virginia tech so why don't
we go ahead and start hear me now all
right good I'm a wanderer so I've always
wanted to do this after i finish i can
just drop the mic right okay um so i'll
let me start off can you make sure their
self okay all right so uh indulge me for
a few seconds while I sort of preach to
the choir and try to tell a poignant
story of why you're doing it why doing
one mark IV all right so this is an
image from the anti-war demonstrations
in San Francisco you can see City hole
in the background in 1967 all right so
if you ask a historian like Ian here
when does an event become history no
he'll say something like you know 20 to
30 years later all right so this means
that the history of the 60s were
actually written in around the 80s right
and so that brings us to present day
anybody recognize this person don't
don't say it i have a reveal but
alright so this person okay what about
this image if you didn't recognize the
previous one okay so the big fun thing
is this see that this place okay that
that totally did not work alright so I
ok we know what he said all right so um
so that's Monica Lewinsky right who had
a fair with a president bill clinton and
he she recently stepped back in the
limelight and gave a TED talk about it
and this is what she said so briefly you
know when the story was broken 1998 was
the first time the traditional news was
usurped by the internet for a major news
story all right and so the question I
want to post you guys are you know so
where those web pages now all right so
if an event becomes history and we start
exploring at 20 to 30 years later it
means we're getting ready to write the
history of the 1990s right about now all
right and so this this is a very
interesting question right can you write
a history of the 1990s without the web
all right and so let me ask you this
where those web pages now right this is
of course a rhetorical question right we
know where those web pages are right you
know Brewster had had that foresight a
long time ago to say hey you know this
web thing it's probably going to be big
you know somebody should keep a copy of
these webpages around right which is
really visionary and then it's sort of
expanded so I got this from a Wikipedia
page about what archiving there over 70
plus web archiving efforts around the
world all right okay so where does web
page is now we do have them right so the
next question is okay let's do something
with it that's get to work that's do
some scholarship right and I think this
is where we start running into some
issues here right some of you that heard
my talk before have seen this slide
before right so to be honest I think we
have the sort of a chicken and egg
problem right right now users can't do
that much with
web archives and so on and on the flip
side sort of the egg side it's hard to
develop tools for non-existent users all
right because there are no users you can
develop tools and you know you can't you
can't get around this right so I've been
advocating and this is slide some of you
probably seen before it that what we
really need is these deep collaborations
between users archivists historians
usual humanists etc librarians and tool
builders like myself computer geeks
essentially right so we need to develop
tools that support exploration and
discovery in web archives and so what
what's happened is and going beyond
browsing going beyond searching right so
what's happened is I basically taken my
own advice right so I met yen this is
his slow smiling face about a year ago
and we've been engaged in an
increasingly intensive collaboration
essentially him on the user side and me
on the tool builders side right so I'm
going to start here by telling you a
little bit about the tool side and I'll
switch over and he'll talk a little bit
about the user side right so from the
technical perspective the questions that
we've been asking ourselves is you know
what would a modern web are you plot
what our web archiving platform built on
big data infrastructure look like right
so before we get to that you have to
think about you know what are sort of
the criteria what are the desiderata
that you need right so you got to store
the data all right you got to have
efficient random access because you want
to pull down records you want to have
scalable analytics and scalable
processing and then finally you're going
to have derive data then you want to
store and access somehow right so how we
currently do that you doing this right
so Internet Archive has a pita box
architecture and most organizations
today are still using sans network
attached storage so relatively expensive
sword solutions right in terms of
efficient random access you have the
open wayback machine but it's sort of
showing its age you know it's a
monolithic monolithically integrated
tomcat application and you know we'd
like to move something that's more
loosely decouple and service-oriented
and in keeping the architecture of the
times right in terms of scalable
processing analytics we're actually
doing quite well
and our work built on a lot of this
there's been lots of work by the
internet archive and the common crawl
about using Hadoop for a scalable
analytics and that that's really a good
thing and then the final the fourth
point is this derived data it's so far
we've been using ad hoc storage and wet
files which i think is a ad hoc and
temporary solution and it still has its
sort of rewards right so the way I look
at it you know the existing tools aren't
aren't adequate and so what do we need
well to me I think the solution is a
combination of Hadoop and HBase and so
I'll run through these technologies very
quickly but basically what we want to do
is we want to use a HDFS the Hadoop
distributed file system for storage we
want to use a Hadoop for the analytics
and processing we want to use each base
for efficient random access and also
keeping track of the derived data and
providing access to it right so let me
run through the technologies very
quickly so at the bottom is HDFS which
is the Hadoop distributed file system
it's an open source implementation of
Google's file system and the intuition
is simple it takes your data blocks keep
three copies and spreads around your
cluster and this technology is fairly
mature by now scales to hundreds of
petabytes right the second is Hadoop
MapReduce which is an open-source
implementation of Google's MapReduce
framework for processing that allows you
to distribute computations across
hundreds to even thousands of machines
on your cluster and you can access it
through high level higher level
scripting languages like Pig and are
more recently there's been talk about a
new technology called spark which serves
as a very nice replacement for for
MapReduce hey and then finally the the
sort of the third part of the technology
piece is a patch HBase which is an open
source implementation of Google's big
table so technically HBase is a
collection of tables each of which is
represents a sparse distribute a
persistent multi-dimensional sorted map
now that's a mouthful I think Google
calling a big table is much more
descriptive it's a big table has rows
and columns and conceptually that's
really all
and it handles the distributed storage
and scale up okay all right so what
we've been working on for for the last
year or so is this project called work
base which is an open-source platform
for managing web archives built on
Hadoop and HBase and this is with
generous funding from the incentive
program and a little additional funding
provided by the national science
foundation okay all right so let me sort
of give you the life cycle of how work
base works so we assume that you already
got collection development you've done
the crawl using for example archive it
and so you're going to take your work
data and you're going to adjust it into
HBase and then you're going to use
MapReduce pigs spark and we have
examples all all these for processing
and analytics text analysis link
analysis I won't say that much because
that's what Ian's going to actually talk
about in a few minutes and and then the
HBS itself serves as a platform for
serving your applications and providing
external facing services okay so oh no
this image didn't come out this came
from a sort of a promotional photograph
we took recently at Maryland normally we
don't stand around in the data center
pointing at machines right but of course
we got work base running on our in-house
clusters which is exactly what was meant
for right so we got work base to run
here now what's Rahl so interesting as
Ian and his his team have gotten work
base to run here also anybody recognize
what that is that's a that's a mac pro
so it's a basically a desktop machine
and so I call this work based in a box
or more accurately it's actually a
cylinder all right another interesting
thing is uh and ian will show you the
demo that it is possible to run work
base here also on your laptop right so
you can have portable work base all
right so what's the big deal about this
I'm why do I think this is a game
changer and it's it's the following so
historians probably cannot afford Hadoop
cluster right so we have a 25 node
Hadoop cluster it's fairly sizable and
chunky and it was a
chunk of change to to purchase it right
but they can probably afford a mac pro a
desktop machine or or a macbook right
and and so how will this change
historical scholarship if we essentially
broaden the ability for people to get
access to historians and other humanists
and social scientists to get access to
these technologies right so we're
measuring a processes like this where i
can start off with visual graph analysis
on the longitudinal data you select
subsets for the examination and then you
drill down examine individual pages and
then you go from distant reading to
close reading right and you can do it
all from your desktop or laptop right
okay and then as a final bonus we've
gone to work based to run on this does
anybody recognize what this is this is a
this is a Raspberry Pi right so this is
a we've gotten it to run here and this
is a computer the size of a credit card
and it's about the price of three
cocktails here in Manhattan all right
and so why is this the big what why is
this a big deal so what this allows you
to do is score every page that you ever
visited in your pocket right so think of
this as browser bookmarks meets life
logging on steroids right throw in a
little bit of analytics like and say hey
you know how much time did I waste on
reddit in the last week most people
probably don't want to know the answer
to that question right but you can you
can start doing those types of things so
yeah what will you do now in moving in
the future if you can carry a sizable
chunk of the web in your pocket on a
raspberry pi where future iteration of
the Raspberry Pi form factor right and
how will this change how you interact
with a web I think those are really
interesting questions okay so what can
you really do with work base let me put
up Ian again and throw the throw the
podium over okay thank you
I promise not really I'm not really drop
the mic
that's all right hi everybody you
already know who I am because you've
seen my face so I'm a historian who's
been really really interested in working
with web archives because I think that
historians at the very base level are
fundamentally unprepared to engage with
the quantity of digital sources that are
going to transform what we do as
historians the advent of the web both
with born digital sources that can shed
so much light on human culture and
activity after the advent of web
archiving of roughly ninety six for our
big collections as well as other traces
of the past presents a profound
challenge things that are had would
never things that would never have been
preserved before are now being preserved
and that gives us unparalleled
opportunity and as Jimmy noted I don't
think you can study the 1990s or Beyond
if you don't consider the world wide web
and that's true for me as a social and
cultural historian that's true for
military historian is going to get the
voices of rank-and-file soldiers that's
true for a political historian that's
going to be able to trace elections
follow the everyday process of
policymaking and so forth the web is not
a perfect democracy there's cleavages of
ACE race and class people who access all
the web people who access on mobile but
we can't forget that we're still
expanding the amount of information
being preserved so no as Jimmy said we
can't do the 90s if you don't do web
archiving and if we don't start thinking
about how to access us now we're going
to get left behind because at the end of
the level my own vision is the historian
is of course are probably preaching to
the choir here the wayback machine isn't
going to be enough for serious historic
research and my nightmare scenario is
that if we don't start thinking about
critically book tools we're just going
to rely on date ordered keyword search
results like historians already do with
ocr'd newspapers stabs in the dark
cherry picking data don't understand how
their databases work we'll get left out
of post 1996 research just like
historians as a profession kind of got
left out of the culture amex Google
Ngram project because we don't like
numbers we don't play well with others
and all sorts of things and so I think
this is something we actually need to
start worrying about now and so luckily
I found Jimmy he put a picture of me up
if I had put a picture him up and we've
been playing around with what we can do
with work base and so the area that I
want to talk about today is some of the
work we've been doing with unlocking an
archive it collection so as people in
this room know our
private has amazing collections of
social cultural political and economic
records generated by everyday people
leaders business community academics and
beyond there are literally millions of
stories of historical interest waiting
to be told in those collections the data
is there but the problem is how can you
actually access it as a historian and so
we use an example data set to sort of
you know prototype out what we can do
with work base and internet archive
collections and we've been primarily
working with over the last few weeks and
months on archival collection 227 which
is the Canadian political parties and
political interest groups collected by
the University of Toronto libraries and
I want to thank them for for working us
with that with us as well it's a pretty
robust longitudinal data set it starts
in october two thousand five and it
continues to crawl we can get data as
soon as they get it and it consists of
all the major Canadian political parties
of which there's four or five depending
on who's counting let's say five as well
as minor political parties and organized
political interest groups such as the
Assembly of First Nations to coalition
to host the arm Trades Council of
Canadians etc the who's who of the
Canadian political sphere one problem
has been that it was started in 2005 by
now retired librarian so trying to find
out their rationale for the seed lists
the biases within the collection I've
actually been pretty challenging and
sort of skew some of the results we
found and so the two main approaches
that we've been taking that we are going
to unify are using work base for Link
instruction and analytics using work
base for you know specific full text
extraction and analytics and then also
playing around with full-text faceted
search using the UK web archive shine
front end to up to a solar index and I
want to start by talking about work base
so we've been using work base to analyze
links and full-text we can do basic link
statistics and this is really important
when we're actually starting to generate
numbers we can count the number of pages
per domain how many pages are ad liberal
CA 2008 that sort of matters if we're
going to normalize things count the
number of links for each crawl so we can
make sense of it all their spikes and
dirty data all over the place and all of
these things can be run on the command
line using relatively simple pig scripts
and so we'd like to come up a sort of a
cookbook that historians can adapt and a
research team can just change little
variables and we'll walk them through it
Jimmy mentioned pig although just as I
start learning pig he's going to switch
to pie spy
but that's okay here's a pig script it's
relatively human readable and you can
make sense of what you're counting you
know one O'Reilly book and you're
starting to figure out what's going on
in there so here for example playing
with Link instruction we decided let's
look at social media appearances let's
see who are the first people in this
collection use Twitter for example and
we can see here that outside of Creative
Commons Prime Minister Canada actually
Prime Minister's Office of Canada
started using Twitter before the main
opposition parties than the NDP and the
Liberals and the Green Party got on
board the actual conservative party of
canada didn't come along to a bit later
facebook as well we can see the liberal
started it off the Green Party and the
sort of slow distribution of people
actually hopping onto facebook
politically in 2007 in canada by taking
the links and turning them into domain a
greeting to my domain we get data like
this so here we're saying you know 2008
that's october two thousand eight
conservatives linked to dig 2325 times
they linked to facebook the same amount
so clearly was probably a header or
footer linking to these things and you
just get these massive data rate they're
not that big the whole thing for about
five six years is only 1.2 megabytes oh
it's the kind of thing you can work with
easily put into gaffey super quickly and
here again we're seeing the liberals
linking a few years later i mean so that
lets us tell stories so this is just in
gebi the contrast doesn't work too well
on the screen but I can kind of explain
what's going on if can be good and so
we're seeing ya
this is st. Louis pointing falooda
master generated by Jeffrey and so the
liberal party of canada and if you look
at the sort of cluster of a robot CA you
see that's overwhelming the point of
this technology on webca we see the rise
of social media liberals are pointing at
Facebook Flickr and YouTube heavily for
first time in december two thousand
seven receive fundraising group we're
seeing the anticipation of a federal
action you don't have your collection to
live in canada to this might be
significant racine pointing over to make
you fun in the phone a little flaw in
the pool party we're seeing announcement
of creature with the media political
party of canada we're seeing election
campaign and the liberals are pointing
out this is deon retronomics brush
harper scandal PDF electrodes and then
not the Liberals website election
they're simply pointing to push our bird
CA oh okay so that's just one example
the kind of stories we can tell and we
can actually use these links to extract
purposes so i've done this like let's
just take a little thing let's read
let's get that full text let's topic
model and it actually lines up pretty
well to what we'd expect to find and so
other things we've been doing with is
finding which mainstream media outlets
do each political party link to and how
does that change over time what think
tanks have influence on canadian policy
platforms and how did the political
parties relate to each other so here for
example we're seeing serendipitously the
left or right wing spectrum of canada of
learning so much but Canadian politics
today there's the NDP in the
left-liberal CA serve at the top and
then the conservative that the side and
you can see which which websites are
linked to only from the NDP the
conservatives liberals which ones are
shared and you could also use that to
build a collection and you can tell
stories I like this that 2005 canadian
federal election the NDP which is our
left-wing party didn't actually really
attack the conservatives the right-wing
party they instead attacked a centrist
party because that's where they're going
to steal votes from essentially or win
votes from and we're so we're seeing
2005 overwhelmingly link structures are
actually mirroring what we would expect
to find text analysis has also been
really useful here's another example of
one of these pig scripts that we find
very useful and you could provide this
to a research team and say just change
lines see in this case we're running it
we're going to get the full text for
Green Party CA and it's actually going
to be arranged in date so full text 2008
10 Green Party
it's going to be the full text for
october two thousand and eight for the
Green Party of Canada CA that lets you
do really cool digital humanities and
other sorts of text analysis if you do
that you get a circumscribed purpose for
liberal TI NDP conservative CA and then
you can do things like topic modeling or
Lda and named entity recognition and the
results there have been interesting
october two thousand five were going
back we see michael chong as fairly
obscure canadian MP now but who was very
very critical at the time before he left
politics and we go of it later and we're
seeing the emphasis on Stephane Dion
even more so in this case on the
conservative web page than the Prime
Minister of Canada themselves they went
very very negative as some astute
observers of the Canadian seen you tell
the trick is visualizing this it's not
the friendliest thing it's hard to get a
research system to go through columns
and columns and columns of any our data
and so I'd like to look into some sort
of this is from the trading consequences
one of the digging into data platforms
sort of a text plot and you could start
seeing your any are things and click on
that and go further into context so that
in a really abbreviated session with
some of the stuff we've been doing with
work base we've also been playing with
shine and so shine is developed by the
UK web archive it's their front end to
interface with their collections right
now indexing we have to get a Hadoop
index are going on because everything's
being really quick indexing takes a long
time so about 250 gigs that works on
that cylinder desktop you saw took about
five days to index and so we need to
actually make it so that scales up
quicker and this index and total is
about ninety gigabytes so I'm going to
switch over to my local browser I hope
it works it's probably today's not going
so well so we'll see and just to give
you a sense this is that same collection
here from 2005 to 2015 and we're looking
at recession and depression and so we
can actually see in Canada how political
tension starts rising in 2008 starts
going very very high and you can
actually click on these browsers you can
see 100 random samples we want to make
it talk to work based because this isn't
very useful 100 random samples from
14,000 websites it's going to be useless
as a historian but you can click on it
and then you can see the faceted options
and in this case we see that right
wingers right more right wing and
centrist websites called the economic
crisis in Canada a recession and the
left-wingers called it a depression or
we can do here in advanced search I like
this we can look up Harper who's the
last name
our prime minister we can look at
fascist which is an embarrassing thing
many opposition people call him and you
do a search and this to me is something
that I think already shows the Green
Party of Canada which is a fairly major
political party in Canada in 2008
actually let peep anybody right on the
website which is political stupidity for
a mainstream political party so it's
full of by 2080 it's gone quickly
thereafter because they obviously
reconsider but we're seeing tons and
tons that word proximity Harper within
25 words of the word flashes and you're
already finding scandals and it's you
know extreme political rhetoric which
would be a great paper and so it's a
pretty robust interface it's not very
big it's pretty easy to serve and all
that code is online from the UK web
archive and we've we've done some
walkthroughs and scripts so you could
get it working on your own collections
pretty pretty quickly the advantages to
it of course is that shine is accessible
to the general public it's easy to use
the interactive trend data lets you dig
right into the data the data comes from
the internet archive so you don't have
to worry about copyright problems the
disadvantage keyword searches you need
to know what you're looking for and
random sampling is so misleading when
you've got tens of thousands of records
etc and that unlike the earlier examples
i showed it doesn't take advantage of
what makes web sources so powerful which
are the hyperlinks so we need to bring
together the hyperlink analysis into
these diagrams to get a much more
sophisticated sense that we need to
build really serious connections between
work base and shine and by doing so you
can truly unlock the power of an archive
it collection and so that's a really
quick walk through hopefully you've got
some great questions for the two of us
it's been a great year I feel like I've
left out a million things that I could
have talked about but I only had 10
minutes not 45 minutes so thank you very
much
um so the if I answer correctly the on
your local machine you are connected to
the framework the cluster in okay so I
mean what you're doing is pretty awesome
so is there an idea of saying building a
sweet so that because i know that in
Virginia Tech I know somewhere me and my
colleagues were actually building a lot
of machine learning algorithms to
analyze archives so if there's a way to
say developer standards so that we could
add to the library I think that would be
yeah thatthat's hello yep that's exactly
the plan so in our experience we found
out that working with ARCA the
collections has been fairly fairly
convenient and it's and so what we're
essentially building is a workflow say
you know here's the here's your archive
a collection do this do this do this BAM
you get your graph visualization run
this pic script you get your link
visualization run this other pic script
you get your named entity you know do
this and then you get imported to shine
and then do full text search yes so it's
we're not quite there yet because we
sort of have to do it on one collection
take the lessons learned generalize it
try it out on the collection and so on
and so forth right but I do want to
emphasize here that we need to go back
and I go to tell my students all the
time that this needs to be driven by the
user right we need to have somebody
that's a user's around and to drive it
from you know what are their substantive
scholarly interesting questions that can
be answered from this and so I think
that's sort of a key component that I
see that's missing from from some some
of the efforts
I have a question um this is the
question I started already know the
answer to and it's maybe more directed
towards Ian but I think it would be some
good added context is sort of what
institutional challenges you may have
encountered in this project and I think
it's something that you know we have
dealt with it i am in mark of it and
that you've probably dealt with from the
user side but speaking to sort of i
don't know that a lot of institutions
are necessarily prepared for the types
of research inquiries that are
interested in these this data and these
services researcher policies user
agreements how you even get the data to
them methods of delivery so could you
speak to some of some of the challenges
was getting the data really women I mean
I know how it went yeah yeah so I worked
with Jefferson I mean that they're the
archiving research services pilot is
great and so I was also working a lot
with the wat files I mean the downside
is you've got archive it you've got the
donor library I don't know if this is
what you're getting at you've got the
donor library university of toronto and
then you've got me literally hundred
kilometers down the road at the
university of waterloo and it took a
long time it took you know took like
four months really to get everybody
online you've t was I think a bit risk
adverse it was going up probably higher
than it necessarily needed to and it
ended up with me driving down and
hanging out it was good and I got some
Christmas shopping down but like hanging
out well we copied all the files onto
hard drive and then literally drove them
back to Waterloo that being said when we
decided to get all the work files that
one almost see that was seamless that
was just a once the user agreement was
signed it was checking a box we could go
in just W get at them all was a long
weekend downloading
it was fine so that's a challenge the
other challenges of course computing
resources which is something all of us
as human his face Jimmy's been great
working with Jimmy because he gave me a
cluster to play around with yeah I have
toys yeah Jimmy Jimmy has toys but it
was also cool because I I code but my
code is really crappy and loops and slow
and inefficient and so work base when we
got it up and running on my local
desktop that was like an aha moment this
is literally something you could go to
the social sciences humanity Research
Council of Canada or like save up your
PR for a few years or something and you
could actually get a computer and you
could run this data set on you know I
ran work based on a terabyte and it was
about 50 minutes to extract all the
links on the desktop machine but that's
that's a kind of efficiency that you
can't get anywhere else at anything so
you've been working with archive at
selective collections and i'm not i'm
not sure how the results that have been
produced for what proportion of the web
is is archived for general collections
apply to our cab it but how bias do you
think these collections are how much is
missing and how big a problem is this
going to be when jefferson manages to
get this kind of thing running on the
internet archive's main collection yeah
i mean the biases are i've also done
some work with a wide web scrape so the
biases are there they're clued the data
is a lot cleaner and it's more fun to
play with in some ways but the biases
are there I'm in the arc of the
University of Toronto case it was sort
of a rabbit hole I talked to the current
librarian and said hey who did this
collection who made this collection 2005
and they didn't really know and then
they finally traced it down retired
librarian you know reaching out to her
and talking to it and he kind of got the
sense of 2005 they sat down had a really
quick conversation with what had to do
and realistically it probably has more
of a left-wing bias and a ripened bias
and they were up front with that in some
cases that was a contour of 2005 the
left was more organized and then it
brings up all sorts of questions like
who is maintaining this seed what
decisions were made all these sorts of
things that make those pretty trend
charts that would be so attractive I
think to the general public make them a
bit suspicious when it comes
to human decisions made in 2005 and ad
hoc collecting changes made over the
following ten years and so if we work
with it we have to be very very clear
you know how this collection was was
created and ideally people will document
that when they create their seeds
because as a historian if I use that in
a paper the first peer review comment I
get back I would probably make it myself
would be how was this data generated
what's the bias in the data how can I
trust the things that you're coming up
with yes
yeah ya know the comparative statistics
would be cool and now that we've got
more space knock on wood I've been doing
quite a bit of work with wide 0002 which
is this 80 terabytes scrape of the web
from March to December 2011 and it would
be neat to see even if we just took the
see a top-level domain which to put
eight million web pages which is a
feasible number to work with line that
up and compare it to the archival
collections it would be cool the
downside is with archive it because
archive ennis is cool with this and
university toronto is really on board
dirt they're having fun with us that
they've said you can put the stuff
online you can have fun with it as soon
as we get into wide web material and
pretty sure the inner door might not be
happy if we started linking into their
collections too deeply I don't know
maybe Jefferson yeah yeah what's way
have him say into Mike and Sam so in the
first part of Jimmy's presentation I was
sitting here thinking wow I hope to one
day have a collection big enough to
really need work base but then it was
just a few minutes later and you had it
running on a Raspberry Pi and then I
started thinking wait a minute these
guys are crazy they've brought you know
like a wrecking ball to do the weeding
in my garden or something right you know
the overbuilt the tool for very small
gigabyte size collections and so I
wonder what why do that right why bring
those tools to bear on even the small
problems okay so some running out of
time so I'll answer this very quickly I
think the the key factor here is the
uniform framework allows you to reuse
tools from sort of one scale to another
right so that means the the tools that
you're developing for 10 terabytes will
work on 100 gigabytes and tomorrow as
Moore's law of vance's run on your
Raspberry Pi right and so it's the same
exact infrastructure that you can scale
up scale down scale and scale out use a
cluster use your local machine use a
raspberry pi so that that's sort of the
elegance of engineering argument I would
say
does that answer your question okay the
title of this presentation archiving
transactions towards uninterruptible web
service sorry it's a mouthful but I
hopefully I can decipher the whole thing
in the next 20 minutes so this is a
project a collaborative project between
Virginia Tech libraries and computer
science department prashant is a PhD
student from computer science department
advised by my co-principal investigator
dr. Edward Fox who unfortunately isn't
here today so this is a project that
we're trying to build a little tool to
expand web archiving in multiple france
we're trying to break the existing
pattern on who's archiving how we're
archiving and why we're archiving so
this is outline a the I see this a
little project have a very big
motivation I'll explain that a little
bit and I'll give some technical
background of this project i'll show the
system architecture and through a very
simple and easy demo to give you a
better idea on how this works in the
past couple of weeks we're working
heavily on improving the performance of
this tool i'll report some results from
there and also i want to give you an
idea how we position this project in the
wider web infrastructure so how this
small tools can be used by by running
websites um so we're I want to step back
a little bit by looking at who archive
the web what we're archiving how we
archive and why we're archiving so the
first
as there are many service who's already
shown us that the major stakeholders of
web archives our cultural heritage
organizations academia just look around
that's us I don't mean to criticize but
if you go to other web or Internet
related meetings and conferences for
example you're going to web analytics
meetings or information retrieval
conferences and the audiences and the
participants are much more diverse than
this one so my question is why aunt
industries here why there are so few of
them should I put it the other way
wouldn't be more participate help the
web archive in a big deal I think so so
how we're going to do this and then take
a look out at what we have archive is so
far in in in the terms of size I believe
we have archival lots of things but many
studies have shown that up to you now
the web we have archive is far from
enough we probably barely scratch the
surface if you go to Internet Archive
you can see most of the websites
probably have their front page archive
the several times per year and anything
deeper than that well you're out of luck
so is there a way that we can archive
the the web more deeply and then the
current status of the web archiving is
closely related on how we archive it the
survey also shows that the predominant
approach that people take the arc of the
web is the crawler based archiving which
we set off the web crawler to go out and
from the seeds traverse the links and
archive with the crawler sees we already
know for a fact well the products is the
things might be different from what we
see
people and so we don't necessarily got a
full picture of through the archive so
there are many other approaches to
archive the water at the web why are
those approaches well more widely used
so that's the other questions I'm trying
to solve through this little project and
the fourth aspect I want people to think
about is the value proposition why we're
archiving the web so the survey also
shows the predominant value proposition
is the so-called comprehensive public
good we archive the web to preserve the
history and we collect those data for
later research notes can be useful but
as any comprehensive public goods
project indicates there are many
problems of this type of value
proposition we've got loads of free
writers now that internet archive is
archiving my website why should I pay my
own money doing that what is it in it
for me myself if I'm not an archivist
I'm not the library now I'm not
researcher what's in it for me to do
that so these are the questions I want
you guys to think about and this is
exactly the same thing we want to this
little project tries to break into so we
want to expand the value proposition we
want to ask what the web archiving can
do for the potential stakeholders and
participants if you want people to
participate you you've got to give them
something right so one of the potential
participate of web archiving I think one
of the very important ones are the
people who operate the website you have
a website why don't you are cut yourself
so then if we want them to archive
you've got to give them a reason what
matters the most
them so I have a previous life as a
webmaster and this is something that
matters most to me if I'm operating a
website see that 4502 that's an error so
website downtown that's the major issue
for any website most web site once you
operate 24 7 but that's not always
possible and although you put your best
effort things just happens you got as a
webmaster you got beeps at midnight
telling you well your website down you
need to go get up and fix it though so
those are my personally personally I
think those are my worst nightmare I
don't want to get up at four pfoa a.m.
to fix my website and that's usually
can't fix by myself I need the other
people can help me so those are what
matters to web operations so what can we
do to help them as a web archive so this
little idea that I think might have
quite some potentials if we have an
archive that archives every page every
change of that website if your web site
goes down there's a possibility we can
use the archive to filling those down
times your business down and so it
hasn't changed right so your last
updated change last archive the change
is what should be served so we don't
have to go back to this ugly page this
sentence is free I don't know what you
say please try again in 30 seconds
that's all we know I tried in 30 seconds
in multiple cases to go that and nothing
happens it's still the same 502 so if we
have the last update last archived page
in an archive down we can reuse that so
the the thing is we can't just use any
archive to do this dark happens to has
to be a little better than what we have
now so that's the so called the
transactional archive a transactional
archive
in between the web server and the user
it archives almost everything archives
of most 200 results that's getting back
to users so in that sense a transect
transactional archive archives every
page a user gap so so this project boots
on the transactional web archive tool
that's viewed from Los Alamos National
Lab is called Side Story this is open
source tool it's on github so anyone can
download in and take use take advantage
of it this is how the side story works
so
yep so user standard send a request to a
server the server if everything works ok
the server will return the response
that's a 200 response ok the side story
has two components one is an Apache
module it's called ma side story the
other part is tom cat and Berkeley DB
based archive is called side story web
archive so when there is 200 response
generated this module will be loaded
this module will grab the same response
stand back to the user and send this
response archive that into the archive
and this web archive can be accessed by
any users if if there's permission
through memento protocol I'm sure we
have some familiarity with the new
mental protocol so you send a memento
request you will get a new mental
response telling you this as a snapshot
taken at web so this is how the side
story works so our project which we
called an uninterruptible web service we
tries to turn side story into a web
infrastructure component that improves
the website availability and we try to
mask the web server errors from the end
users and this will gain precious time
for webmasters to recover from
application server failure without
disrupting the majority of the users
will experience this is by what we give
them back and hopefully they help us to
to help us do our job better as
archivist and librarian
so this is how the physical uws i
interrupt the web service architecture
looks like this portion of we assume a
typical three level web architecture so
you have a front end server that's
running a paci you have an application
server that deals with the logic and you
have a database asleep behind it so this
is the normal web operation looks like
then we install this part that's this
time sorry thing and we develop this
little thing called mock uws this is
also an Apache model that sits inside
Apache front from answer so with what
this does is so from this architecture
the solid lines depict how the website
works when everything goes okay so these
are the two hundred workflows this shows
how the side story archives a page
typically how it take the archives a
page exactly what i showed in the last
two slides so the dotted line shows how
things should work when something goes
wrong so we have a request comes in a
request through the front end server
usually goes to the application server
now application server is done without
downtime now what if there is a downside
here not what happens is there should be
a 500 errors or 550 1050 two errors sent
back to the application server if
without our body without our our body
what would happen is this 500 error will
be sent back to the general public will
be sent back to the user and that's when
people see the ugly 500 page so what we
did here is through this little model we
intercept this response that ugly page
was not sent back to the user instead we
intercept that response and 37
that request to the side story archive
which will gives us back the last
archive the page then we send this page
back to the user sounds very simple and
hopefully worse next I'll show you next
I show the little demonstration so a
little bit explanation so what this
demonstration is about so I have to I've
two browsers opening the browser on top
shows the visitor log off a website that
is down randomly so I inserted random
error into the application server if it
works it will shows the current time if
it doesn't it shows you the ugly fight
something page so this is what a normal
website should looks like should look
like if without our help the browser
down here is a this shows the visit to a
website that has the same exactly
website but has the help of the uws
so if it works what should happen is you
will never see that ugly 500 page what
you will see us you will you keep
refreshing this page you keep seeing the
last updated time it's the same time
that you see last time
so I'm keeping I'll keep refreshing this
one you see a server error another
server error another server error
another server error another one now you
cut the time got another server error
we've got time it will just keep going
it's not much interested in going on
here so let's see what's going on here
nothing change right if they're there is
nothing change it means uws is working
so throughout this demo you will see
this browser never shows you the server
error there's always some something
coming back okay now it's getting boring
alright so through this little demo I
basically shows the universe Marty we
build works but for something that you
want to pitch as a web infrastructure
component that just work isn't enough it
has to be have fairly good performance
so we've spent the last couple of weeks
trying to improve the performance of the
uws model first I would like to to show
you how the workflow of the uws model
works which I already explained if you
see from here I take I take out all the
other components you see from here you
will see the workflow as Allah and the
winding process as multiple calls and
responses chained together sequentially
give you an analogy your drainpipe would
be more prone to clog if its pretty long
right the longer it is is more prone to
clogging so what we want to do is we
don't want a really long process that
depends on each other change
sequentially so we're trying to reduce
the length of the pipe a limit on the
other hand our contribution the uws
module sits right in front of the
archive we don't want the uws modding to
be to be in the bottleneck which means
if you're providing ups a standby
battery standby service you don't want
the switch to be a limiting factor for
your battery you want the battery to
work hundred percent so in order to do
this we take a little bit of adventure
to look at the current implementation of
the side story on the be mental request
no response the current side story
implements the most frequently used me
mental request and response which is for
pattern 1.1 which is typical content
negotiation
or a 330 to kind of response that
requires two round-trip request and
response but momento a protocol also
allows us to do the pattern for a much
simpler request and response without
doing the two round trips so what we did
in past couple weeks is we extend the SI
star implementation to add a pattern for
implementation and then we did a
performance test it's probably too much
to explain what all those are but the
the end result is we were able to reduce
the uws load by about one-fourth to
one-third while we reduce the uws load
we did not significantly increase the
size story archive load so that's first
sounds like a total game so now what I
want to explain is how do we see the uws
can be positioned in the in the larger
web infrastructure especially how it's
really related to the other related
components for example web cache if you
understand what I'm saying you can see
how uws works inside sorry works has
quite some celerity similarities with
web cache web cache also caches some
responses and use the same responses to
respond to other requests right so what
are the relations between the uws module
and the web cache the differences i can
say immediately as a web cache as a fish
is efficiency p it's not a safety tool
to be a little bit more elaborate the
web cache helps the helps the web
requests in response to be faster more
efficient have the same user experience
actually have better user experience but
the web cache does not necessarily
maintain a full complete copy of the
website
this is usually because the cash is more
expensive the size is limited or the
cash is geographically located far away
from the from the region server and the
web cache can evict copies as necessary
as it sees feet and therefore in order
to maintain the so called semantic
transparency of the of the web which
means with or without the cash the user
should seize the same results if we need
to maintain the semantic transparency
then the web cache needs to fall back to
the region server from time to time
fairly frequently fall back to the
region server so this is why web cache
is a fairly good efficiency tool but you
can't use that to prevent something
happening if the original Sarah's gone
is going down that's why there's a major
differences between the web cache and
and the uws model we're developing oops
this is ok so the end the other
comparison between the web archive and
the backup tool people always asking
well many webmasters webmaster look at
me when we're trying to elicit them to
do some web archiving the first
responses we Becca our website or every
day why do I need to do web archive so
why why do we need to do a web archive
but here's the reason you you back up
your website every day you back up the
whole database in one file trying to
respond to one simple error you need to
extract the whole back up and put the
whole back up to replace your current a
website so the frequency is too low and
the granularity of the archive of the
backup is to pours for the purpose of
what we're doing here so these are the
how I see the difference is how we
position the UW has small you as a web
components that's pretty much what I
have to say thank you very much
I can answer questions sign for the
backup you said that the frequency is
too low doesn't that assume that the
pages are being visited because isn't
that when the pages get cached sorry
that's about backup are you asking about
back hobble the cash you you were saying
that the back up back up for this year's
team service back up right so normal
normally the website back up there the
whole database and application every day
so there is something happening wrong in
the middle of the day then all you can
revert back as a day before so you can't
revert back to what exactly when the
error happens that's why I'm saying the
backup frequency is too low for the
purpose of using uws I know this is a
new project sorry see they're too loud
or too soft but have you started any
conversations yet with website owners of
whether or not they'd be interested in
using this yet this whole thing started
from our conversation with the website
owners actually we talked with a
university relations in Virginia Tech
which runs the vt.edu website their
first I've already described what their
first responses which is the driven
driving forces that that we actually
developed this project so we're at this
moment trying to launch this on to the
Virginia Tech College of Engineering and
computer science department website
after this initial rollout then we'll go
back and talk with the University
Relations about larger deployments
so this is potentially useful for
webmasters I mean we actually have a
similar problem with Stanford but it
doesn't really help archiving because it
doesn't get the content out of the
custody of the original publisher which
is the essential part of archiving
leaving it in the custody of the of the
original publisher it's just another
piece of their website doesn't help I
told answer we're saying but if we start
by asking their content we're going to
be boggled down into who else accountant
at how the cannon can be carried over so
what I see this project is a starting
point as at least we can get them to
archive their stuff then we're talking
about what to do with the archive so I I
had a question it sounds like the
uninterruptible Atia of the system
partly depends on the problem that
caused the down in the first place so
for example I imagine something like a
denial of service attack would attack
the whole system and this won't prevent
that if I understood properly but that's
true actually we I don't see this as a
silver bullet that can tackle every
problem of a website of operation this
particular project two tackles the
application server errors which can cost
can be caused by you launched new coat
the new code cause problems or the new
code isn't tested for higher load so
this thing's happens at midnight when
something happens to you so I just
wanted to respond to David commentaires
0 mighty developed side story just as a
tool to you know capture a website you
know so not in this kind of context but
just as another capturing pair
come back to your question these two
things first of all the archive can sit
remotely so in our case the archive of
the memento site and all sit in the
Amazon Cloud so not into Los Alamos
environment and second integral with the
tool is a work download possibility and
so you could hand it over and load it up
in another archive so it's really
capture tool you capture at the source
you can archive elsewhere and another
no no I think it's a misinterpretation
this is about completely capturing the
history of certain server which you can
ever do using web crawling approaches so
it's just another paradigm to capture
the stuff it's every time that the page
get seen right so really is published
because someone saw it it also gets
archived so you get the highly granular
web or capture of what your website is
doing and and that you cannot flow to
another archive if you want yes it's the
same yes no that's actually not true
it's not true because it can operate
elsewhere and you can hand it over as a
word file well that's why you have to
distinguish between what you is doing
and what side story does okay this
sounds like a good conversation for the
the after meeting reception thank you
guys very much courage